ha isn't life great you start the
session and the first game you get us
tickets or the gas okay so what is his
rating 2 519 going to play we're going
to play one of his games and those games
where nothing ever happens and we go see
5 this is the new idea since I guess new
for him usually goes with 97 but this is
also yeah not a very exciting position
but we know the deal so man maybe go
here to avoid the early Bishop g4 making
things you more ya [ __ ] exciting you
know okay yeah a while ago I really
changed my approach to the games against
him I just now play I mean he hit her he
plays this very young simplifying kind
of game and I just don't try to do
anything fancy just try to be quick not
lose on time and it will become the draw
in most cases so i don't mind getting a
couple of rating points
the real issue is that um I have
problems with his openings I have a hard
time to find anything or get anything
yeah remotely exciting against what he
is playing it's just that it's got that
super solid rubber [ __ ] and I have
nothing great so I always get this kind
of stereo sterile whatever yeah you know
what I'm talking about those kind of
position where nothing happens trying
for Bishop a six now you will probably
go back to c5 I assume no I can go
before yeah it's not nothing bad about
it okay just have a drawback it my idea
like take stakes be five
now my dear might be okay I can so
strengthen my position a little bit and
see what he's doing
not sure that this was such a such a
great idea I mean it doesn't harm harm
my position but it also doesn't lead to
anything right
do
not much going on but we we know that
yeah we kept this kind of game yeah yeah
I'm actually somewhat better because
Luke c7 essa is in the mix and so what
happens cm oopsie 70 goes roop d7 ok i
think i can improve a little bit first
f3 king f2 and then see what happens
maybe i can go here and then and then
whoops e7 have an eye on that porn yeah
with bishop CA it right mr. only goes
what's now black resign ok so that's 21
points instead of the points for draw he
rarely to place those kind of blunders
he really really does it's a very very
young yeah very blunder free player
usually and yet happened to him yeah the
position was rather uncomfortable I mean
I just I was just happy with this kind
of simple simplified position where it's
very tough to lose if you play quickly
and this is what I tried yeah I was
ahead on the clock the whole time um
yeah it is rather why it was a little
bit more comfortable against the iqp
even though like um yeah shouldn't lose
heat II tried some things that are not
really helping I think rooks if I for
example this this probably doesn't help
g3 not sure it also weakened the light
squares a little bit but i wanted to
some lift for my king yeah he went to
Queenie five okay and now I went Bishop
a6 and I'm I doubt that what he did now
is good that
simplification here this I'm not sure
about maybe he can improve now but this
really feels quite uncomfortable okay
the engine wants to go to eight he
played this which seems I don't know
yeah wookie eight is what the end in
place let's try to understand the point
if I go rook here he has bishop Adria ok
this is this is really not good right so
I'm not going to do this kingi to or
Bishop d3 I think Bishop e3 is quiet and
then it's gone rook c8 okay this is the
thing up he has these ideas and
something like this is the normal
looking move in a way that he can try to
trade with this or can put the bishop PA
and assistance is ok this is ok for him
I can also go up with the King yet
currently this is not such a big deal
this is annoying still and this is
better though than the then the game
continuation I think here it's really
uncomfortable this and now it's not so
easy for him really not this and i went
there should be seven yeah the idea was
that after Luke c7 are coming Luke c7 I
mean this is also checked so that he
cannot play rock d7 I wasn't quite sure
what is moved from should be the
computer wants to play Bishop d3 and
then again this rook see several is
happening yeah this is what the engine
wants to wants to play defend the pawn
like that ergo rooks if i go here now I
look these sexist the computer move yeah
it looks very uncomfortable but maybe
it's just just about enough to hold
yeah it's it's not fun for black not at
all but probably you should hold I don't
know this is kind of a real torture
position yeah anyway I'm glad to have
won this game a score still absolutely
terrible against them but recently I
think it was kind of ok I played many
drawers now I want a game it's it gets
better ok thanks for watching